وسط المعارك وتحت مرمى النيران لم تتوقف
ندى موسى ورفقائها من مواصله عمليات
الاعداد الخاص برياضه العاب القوى هنا
بمدينه نيالا ولايه جنوب دارفور الغربيه
السودان المعارك والتراث بين الجيش والدعم
السريع لم تمنعهم من التمسك بحلمهم حلمينو
عمل انجاز في الولايه في السودان عام يعني
اكون لعبه دوليه في السودان وخارج السودان
والله رغم المشاكل دي احنا ما وقفنا من
تماريننا مواصلين في التمارين رغم
الضغوطات الحاصله دي شغالين فيها اربعه
اعوام كامله ظل الفريق يواصل الاعدادات
بهدف المشاركه في اولمبياد باريس هذا
العام المدرب المشرف عليهم يتمنى عوده
الاوضاع الى طبيعتها لاستكمال المشوار عن
احنا الان يعني في مرحله اولمبيادة باريس
اقتربت والان بامور بازمه التخطيط بتاعنا
حناخذ معسكر في اثيوبيا او في كينيا اعداد
لكن للاسف الان كلها يبدو بانه احلامنا
حلم بتاع سته خمسه سنوات مجهود تمارين
صباح مساء جبال سهول مرتفعات يبدو بانها
سوف تتبخر لانه الان الوضع لا يسر لا يسر
وانت تعلم ذلك اقليم دارفور ظل لسنوات
عديده يشهد ظروفا معقده بسبب الحرب
والنزوح المتواصل
وبات الطريق الاوحد لتجاوز هذه الصعاب هو
سعي الدائم لبلوغ الاهداف وتحقيق الاحلامة
ونحن كلاعبين والله ممارسين تمارين على
حسب الكوارث اللي وقعت فينا وبذلك نتحدث
لكي يعني مستوانا ما ينزل لان اللاعبي او
القوه لو وقف من التمارين الاعداء بتاعه
بتقل ما بينفع الفائز في حرب نادي خسران
بصراحه
يعني احنا بقدر ما نملك بخدر ما نملك من
مجهود رياضي نحاول ننمي الوطن ما بنحاول
ندمر الوطن على الرغم مما تمر به البلاد
بمصاعب يظل الحلم قائما من اجل صناعه واقع
افضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات